good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I
spent last week in Davos Switzerland
which most of the time is a fairly
standard alpine ski village there
souvenir shops babies and sleds horse
restaurant cults and you know Alps but
one week a year Davos has taken over by
the World Economic Forum a strange and
wondrous throng of CEOs world leaders
scientists and a lot of security guards
who are ostensibly coming together to
improve the state of the world
much of the action happens behind closed
doors we're like EU and American
diplomats try to hammer out a compromise
over internet privacy concerns for
instance or CEOs work out business deals
but the whole town is transformed for
this week into a fevered pitch for
investment and growth and change we're
told to think India but also think
Mexico and Kazakhstan and particular
regions of India and also think
Salesforce and Microsoft and Accenture
and Bank of America and on and on there
was an intensity to the whole thing I've
never really felt before it was a week
of business and politics and activism
smashing together and everyone seemed to
feel that they could actually change
history like increase prosperity achieve
gender parity educate the world and of
course there's something naive about all
that but as I heard an artist say at one
point in Davos perhaps naivete isn't
something to be ashamed of but something
to embrace the other thing Davos gets a
lot of flack for is its elitism and
there was a weird wealthy provincialism
about some of the people I met for
instance they kept asking me where I was
based rather than where I lived as if
the life of a Davos man and they are
overwhelmingly male was to international
and sophisticated just like live
somewhere and then when I explained that
I lived in Indianapolis people almost
always asked why I resisted the urge to
say partly because of people like you
asking questions like that in general I
found the social hierarchies of it all
exhausting at times like of all the ways
the billionaire class could have
organized their social order they seemed
to have chosen as a model the American
middle school and yeah it was wonderful
it was wonderful to see so many people
attending concise and clear minded
discussions of why climate change is
happening and how it's gonna change
human and non-human life it was
wonderful to see the global goals posted
everywhere reminding us of the
commitments that we have made to
ourselves and it was wonderful to meet
with representatives have saved the
children and the UN's refugee agency to
learn about the big challenges of
improving the health care and education
of the world's most vulnerable people
also I learned tons about everything
from virtual reality movies being made
in refugee camps to research being done
on peer learning to the perils of eken
in equality and one particular
recommendation after I met the filmmaker
sharmeen obaid Chinoy at Davos I watched
her oscar-nominated documentary about
honor killing in Pakistan and it is one
of the most powerful movies I have ever
seen right but anyway Hank all week long
I kept thinking about Karim Hussein
who's a father living in the on awadhi
slum in Mumbai and at one point in her
book behind the beautiful forevers
Catherine boo reports Hussein is saying
everybody in on irwadi talks like this
oh I will make my child a doctor a
lawyer and he will make us rich it's
vanity nothing more your little boat
goes west and you congratulate yourself
what a navigator I am and then the wind
blows you East again and again at Davos
I found myself up against the ancient
question of whether people make history
or history makes people and how power
and poverty shape our answers now I know
this is easier to say from a privileged
position up high in the Alps but I do
believe that human progress is possible
even if it isn't inevitable and I remain
both convinced of and deeply moved by
the radical hope that has defined so
much human effort over the millennia for
me this is actually typifying by
Charmaine's movie which inspired the
prime minister of pakistan to finally
belatedly denounce honor killing which
is a small but real step toward a better
world Hank in the coming weeks I'm gonna
look at some of the big problems I left
Davos thinking about income inequality
climate change the refugee crisis and
the ways that gender inequality effect
poverty nerdfighters let me know in
comments if there are other global human
challenges you'd like to see us discuss
Hank I have the jet lag so I'm going to
take a nap I will see you on Friday